and a CBS News poll out this morning 55%
of Americans say the president's view
that both sides were to blame for the
violence in Charlottesville is
inaccurate but 68 percent of Republicans
think the president is accurate
mark Strassmann spoke with three women
who continue to support President Trump
when you saw Charlotte's for what 1/3 of
mind the writing's been on the wall for
years I'm just waiting for the civil war
to start it wasn't necessarily a
completely black-white issue but I think
that the media is turning it into a
black-white issue you can't erase
history you know whatever I mean Wendy
when do you draw the line you know do
you do we now tear down Mount Rushmore
what'd you think of the president's
response was it appropriate he did come
out and he condemned it but how many
more times are is he gonna have to kind
of damn it when the president said
they're fine people on both sides when
you have agitators on both sides what
you expect to happen but shouldn't the
leader of the country be setting a
certain tone do you think he hasn't the
man has been in office for 200 days and
he's getting blamed for stuff that
started 3 4 5 years ago I don't look at
him as you know my pastor or my moral
leader I look at him as the leader as it
relates to governmental issues we're not
looking for somebody
charming we're looking for a man who
knows how to turn things around and he's
got a track record of turning things
around all the women agree that more
needs to be done to stop violent
confrontations from happening